Of the world’s eight largest economies, five
command nuclear weapons — the United States,
United Kingdom, China, India, and France.
Another two — Germany and Italy
— host American nuclear weapons.
Only one, the third-largest, has
neither built, nor borrowed them: Japan.
But Japan doesn’t just object to nuclear war.
Among East Asian countries, only Taiwan
employs fewer active troops — though just
marginally, and yet with 1/5th the population.
When you include reserve and paramilitary members,
Japan’s armed forces are nearly six times
smaller than the next closest East Asian country.
Of course, number of troops is
but one component of defense
and no single figure can possibly
capture the overall strength of a nation.
Japan is certainly not “weak” by global standards.
Its neighbors, however, are exceptionally
strong, and its region especially precarious.
This bar represents the total defense expenditure
in East Asia from 1994 to the present.
During the 90s, Japan alone commanded nearly 40%
of the pie. Then, for all but one of the next
20 years, its share declined, until
it ended up at just 10.7% in 2019.
The missing context, you might argue, is China.
Add it to the mix and it may seem as though
Japan’s defense expenditure hasn’t so much
fallen as China’s has exploded —
dwarfing all others by comparison.
But an even closer examination
shows that despite this increase,
Russia and South Korea have managed
to keep up — whereas Japan has not.
Today, the country finds itself a mere stone's
throw away from not one but three nuclear powers.
Since 1958, its fighter jets have been scrambled
over 30,000 times — a large and increasing portion
of which have occurred in the last 20 years
in response to Chinese and Russian incursions.
And when North Korea fired a ballistic
missile directly above a Japanese island
home to 5 million people in
2017, many began to wonder…
Is Japan’s laudable devotion to Pacifism
compatible with the challenges
of the 21st Century?
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and
Nebula — where you can watch the
exclusive bonus video which accompanies this one.
The simplest measure of military
strength is expenditure.
It stands to reason that the more a nation spends,
the better prepared it’s likely to be for war.
From this perspective, Japan seems
quite formidable — especially when
the two outliers — the U.S.
and China — are excluded.
It sits in the same league as
Germany, France, and South Korea.
But there are a number of
reasons expenditure alone can
be misleading — and that’s perhaps never
been more true than in the case of Japan.
First, the most important
question is on what does it spend?
This is its 2021 defense budget.
The single largest component
— 43% — is maintenance.
This is a broad category that includes
everything from healthcare to education,
and fuel. But roughly half this money
is spent on just one thing: repair.
As the most earthquake-prone country on
earth, Japan simply has more things to fix.
In 2011, the Tohoku earthquake and subsequent
tsunami became the 2nd most costly natural
disaster in recorded history — totaling somewhere
between 2 and 3 hundred billion US dollars.
An estimated 700,000 buildings were at
least partially destroyed in the process.
The third most expensive
disaster, another earthquake,
also occurred in Japan — 16 years earlier.
Because its defense budget
is for the most part fixed,
this leaves much less room for everything else.
Research, development, and equipment procurement
each comprise less than 4% of the overall budget.
The second most important question when it
comes to defense spending is: for how much?
Here Japan is at a severe disadvantage.
In 1976, its Prime Minister banned
the sale of military hardware to
any nation under any circumstances
as part of its commitment to peace.
That left Japanese defense companies
with exactly one potential buyer,
and not just any buyer, but a defense company’s
least favorite kind: a staunch Pacifist.
While American contractors like
Lockheed Martin make nearly all
their money from defense, of Japan’s 10
largest, only two make more than 3% from it.
Why bend backward trying to please one
very picky customer, while tarnishing
one’s reputation when there are millions of
enthusiastic consumer electronics customers?
Banned from selling overseas, its companies
devoted few resources to their defense divisions.
This disinterest, in turn, discouraged investment
from the government — making
them even less competitive.
For a country famous for manufacturing, its arms
contractors have fared remarkably
poorly in international rankings.
Japan, in other words, was forced to either
buy expensive equipment domestically,
or import expensive equipment from abroad —
making it more dependent on others in the process.
After 40 years, the export ban was finally
lifted in 2014. Under the new rules, sales
are allowed so long as their nature is purely
defensive and quote “contribute to world peace”.
Despite this, Japan lost to France in 2016, and
just now, the U.S., in selling submarines to
Australia. Its lack of infrastructure meant
it could only promise one submarine a year.
And while its first deal has since been struck,
other countries will still
have a 40-year head start.
Its equipment may have a reputation for high
quality, but it also has one for high prices.
Now, earthquakes and overpriced
equipment are significant
obstacles — but they are just obstacles. Given
the requisite effort, political will, and time,
Japan could, in theory, overcome them.
Unfortunately, it faces another, much larger
challenge. One for which
no law could possibly fix.
War requires soldiers. Soldiers are made of
humans. And Japan is rapidly running out.
For a country to maintain its population — to
neither grow, nor shrink — the average woman
needs to have just slightly over two children
in her lifetime — one to replace each parent.
China fell below this “replacement
level” of fertility in 1991.
Russia in ‘89. And Vietnam in ninety-nine.
The world average is trending downwards,
which is to say, most of the world is aging.
Japan — with a fertility rate of just 1.3
children per 2 adults — is no exception.
The only difference is that it began this process
way, way earlier — about 20 years
before the rest of East Asia.
China’s population decline is just
getting started, but in the last 10 years,
Japan has already lost 1.5 million people.
During this decade, it will lose another
8 million. In the 2030s, 10 million more.
It doesn’t just lack people — it lacks the right
kind — those young enough to fight for the nation.
By 2050, 40% of the country will be aged over
65. Setting aside the economic consequences
this will bring, first and foremost, this
creates a simple problem of manpower.
The broader labor shortage makes
it difficult for the government
to compete with the generous wages and
benefits offered by private employers.
The country hasn’t been able to find
enough soldiers since 2014. In 2018,
it was forced to lower its standards — increasing
the maximum age for new recruits from 26 to 32.
As a result, the average age of its soldiers is
now 35 — a full decade older than the rest of
East Asia. Even if these soldiers could make up
for youthful strength with wisdom or experience,
they face a different kind of problem. In
short: too many chiefs and not enough Indians.
Most places in the world solve
this problem the same way:
If too few people voluntarily sign up,
the government will simply force them.
Conscription is widespread across East
Asia. South Korea takes a roughly 20-month
chunk out of the lives of its
young men. Until recently,
those in Taiwan had to put their
lives on hold for around a year.
But political and cultural opposition ensure the
Japanese armed forces will never have this option.
And while it’s true that technology
can help supplement human forces,
military strength is relative and its
neighbors will have no harder time
acquiring or developing new weapons and
capabilities — in fact, the opposite.
In truth, no one knows how prepared
Japan is for conflict — not even Japan.
The very nature of war is such that an
outcome is never truly known until it actually
occurs. As a Pacifist nation, Japan has no
modern data points on which to extrapolate.
Having never fired a bullet in combat for 70
straight years, and with commanders who have
never in their life witnessed war firsthand,
making predictions is especially fraught.
Even its equipment remains untested.
Some Mitsubishi-made tanks were found to lack
contingency space for injured soldiers. They
had been designed, built, and tested in sterile,
lab conditions — far removed from the battlefield.
Another reason its capabilities are difficult
to objectively assess is deliberate obfuscation.
Officially, Japan has no aircraft carriers
— which have an offensive association — No,
instead it operates defensive “helicopter
destroyers” — you be the judge.
The nation’s historical aggression,
combined with its now longstanding
peaceful and neutral stance both
constrain its available options.
Behavior that might go unnoticed elsewhere is
met with great suspicion thanks to its past.
By keeping a low profile, Japan
reassures the rest of the world.
Yet, by doing so, even the smallest molehill
of change is perceived by others as a mountain.
Many, including the current government of Japan,
believe any change incremental enough to
avoid attracting attention from its neighbors
would be, by definition, insufficient
to prepare the country for conflict.
Indeed, the 21st century has
brought several new challenges,
each of which would be significant on its own
— North Korea’s acquisition of nuclear weapons,
China’s attempted annexation of Japan’s primary
trade routes, and Russia’s general provocations.
At the same time, Japan must overcome new
impediments — like its shrinking population.
So, why hasn’t the 3rd largest
economy devoted more money,
new laws, or any other measure, for
that matter, to strengthen its defenses?
The ultimate answer has nothing at all to do with
its aging population, lack of combat experience,
or arms export law. The real reason is — next
time, in Part 2, of Japan’s Pacifist Paradox.
But before we answer that question, we need
to take a brief detour to talk about Why Japan
almost has nuclear weapons — a part “1.5”, if
you will, exclusively available on Nebula, where
you can watch bonus and extended videos for just
about every other video you see on this channel.
If you enjoyed this video, you’d
probably like my Nebula exclusive on
why the United States doesn’t face the same
demographic challenges as China or Japan.
You might also like my video explaining
how corporations legally vote in Hong Kong.
Nebula also has full-length Originals
like Legal Eagle’s “Bad law,
Words good”, or TechAltar’s “Technorama”.
Sign up by clicking the link on screen right now,
and for just $15 bucks a year, you also get access
to CuriosityStream, home to great documentaries
like this one on the history of Afghanistan.